welcome to this video playing LC con el
see corn ok ok i doing it again but well
my results are not that bad yeah every
grouping quickly don't want Bishop g5 to
happen ok and interesting you for him
voice is a little bit I'm bad shape yeah
this kind of position i had had quite a
number of times never felt particularly
threatening yeah i can try to gauge one
and play against the pawn their own age
6 i'm trying d5 in the meantime playing
in the center hmm yeah why not
move like night f5s maybe maybe an
option yeah it really is night at five
okay but you will definitely play that
if I could take play deform that is
almost I know actually I can't eat with
the pawn and then night takes because
this Bishop t5 at the end yeah so I can
do this yeah I didn't see that trick
takes Bishop g5 it's not over yet it
really isn't so but I can do this huh if
we stare any better move here I mean
once I play once I moved that night he
will take age six so but this is not bad
if he takes Queen takes here I can still
not take because of this because of it
should be five and if he wants to
threaten this he puts himself in a pin
on the long diagonal so this is actually
really nice if he moves the king then
his queen is unprotected and it still is
not threatening to take now he is
threatening to take but now he also has
weakened his dark squares quite a bit so
night e seven I guess and then 96 or
anything better I don't think so so
Bishop age six and rook takes rook
cheeks 96 Queen f6 that is still a bit
awkward but really is it working
cheeks rook takes notches six Queen f6
Queen d8 takes 26 takes Queen takes 26
king evade no no no that's not really
enough I can escape
yeah I mean if he's not taking on g6 mmm
he has nothing at all just go Queen g
five or so one issue is that the bishop
wants it too was just entirely black
he's an just dad them yeah okay that was
I was really setting that trap basically
that night f5 what would happen the
thing is here he went he went with this
he could have played night at five
immediately and this would have been
very strong I saw that far too late now
I don't have any tricks like a head in
the game and I don't really know what
I'm doing now if I take take this is
very awkward the engine is is giving
this chair and why his bed i acting
edgebrook age one yeah he did this and
now after d 4 i'm better because he
cannot play night at five as we saw and
yeah if he has to retreat his night then
the whole thing doesn't make any sense
yeah like night everyone i just played
this and well there's no attack
whatsoever here and i have a huge space
advantage with white having awful pieces
yeah night f5 was falling right into
that trap yeah like winds IAM white only
can collect yeah hope form for a lucky
break but essentially black is winning
who thanks for watching